sprechen sie Dold westlich von Fribourg
ist das schon fast die Gretchenfrage der
Deutschunterricht ist für viele unserer
französischsprachigen mit alt genossen
der Strafe als Trost oder besser gesagt
jetzt bekommen die geplagten unbeliebten
Deutschlehrer Schützenhilfe von vier
Jungs aus Magdeburg dank der pop-gruppe
Tokio Hotel Geld deutsche in der Runde
neuerdings als cool
kein Kind liest dieses Wunder geschieht
im Welschland
dieser Prozess
Valentin in diesem Jahr
die Stimmung ist schlecht
die Richter
wir
Juni die musste sie fühlte sich durch
die vokale während das Ministerium
genau das trifft es selten selbst nicht
so glatt in Kenia findig deutschen
Schiffen hässlich
vielleicht wird doch noch alles gut mit
der Sprache Bild Torsten Wewer um die
diese drei Freundinnen sammelten einem
Jahr
und Tokio Hotel für ein Konzert nach
Genf zu holen
nun werden sie ärzten Lieder auswendig
fällt daher sicher
wie gefällt es dir nicht geklärt sind
diese haben zwar vieles aber nicht so
konkret sagte er
falscher Alarm
die Einzelheiten
eines der angeblichen Pläne das sind
sie Regeln werden
Fahrten monierten und die sind hier dass
er mit dem Zimmer ist und sagt er will
nur mit ihren die reden reden reden
die arbeiten aber man weiß natürlich
dass es nicht unsere Idee
4 Anthony Hopkins Italiener Dominik
Paris
mutige Anleger
in Schwung die Texte sind wirklich gut
der Wechsel an
wir sehen dann war er Weg ich habe
begonnen die wieder zu besetzen Rheine
man will doch wissen was sie bedeuten so
Seehofer weiter
Kindel aber diese Warnung ich war extrem
schlecht in Deutschland Gesamtsieg aber
Tokio Hotel hat mich motiviert für die
Sprache gelernt und jetzt bin ich die
beste der Klasse ich habe wirklich gute
Noten neue Forderungen
von
tatsächlich retten Tokio Hotel auch das
Image eines die Menschen besonders
unbeliebten Berufsstandes
Deutschlehrer
ihr Problem in der Romandie legten sich
unter dem Einfluss Frankreichs
historisch antideutschen Ressentiments
hartnäckig die Sprache blieb unbeliebt
nun ist die Wende auch hier angekommen
deutsche Musik die aus Deutschland
überhaupt gibt und den Schülern als
cool
ich denke
vor allem in Berlin
wir haben auch Prozent mit dieser Schule
drei Austausch mit Berlin gemacht
und Prozent Berlin ist eine so Bauer
Trelle statt für die Jugend für für
alle
die jüngste Single ist schreiben
unlängst kam Martine Schieber studierte
vor 20 Jahren deutsche Literatur die
Befunde hielten sie für verrückt
damals war ein Phänomen wie Tokio Hotel
unvorstellbar Januar unverändert
bleiben für uns zwar Deutsch ein
bisschen sprachlos in der Schule sagten
sie und sie müssen Deutsch lernen um
einen zielsicheren und arbeiten zu
können so sorgen heute kommen die
Jugendlichen über kulturelle Werte mit
deutschen Kontakt das ändert alles
Koné
dapd